quelles conséquences sur l'environnement
quels effets sur la santé
le déploiement de la 5g suscite des
interrogations et des craintes auprès de
la population
des inquiétudes qui existe depuis le
début du déploiement de la téléphonie
mobile en france à la fin des années 90
récemment une nouvelle menace est
apparue celle de voir pousser un peu
partout ce genre de pylônes à cette
époque les antennes relais indispensable
au développement de cette nouvelle
technologie poussent comme des
champignons et en 1999 sur l'île aux
moines dans le morbihan
elle était loin de faire l'unanimité
abominable
je trouve ça affreux en plus de la
pollution visuelle les riverains
s'interrogent sur les conséquences
sanitaires des antennes relais dans
plusieurs villes
les opérateurs les installe sur les
toits des hlm à angers une association
tirait la sonnette d'alarmé
je pense qu'il faut point attendre que
les locataires servent de cobayes
donc je pense que principe de précaution
doit s'appliquer rapide très très
rapidement et que l'on soustrait enfin
30 et population des environnements aux
ir est suspecté nocifs
début 2000 la téléphonie mobile explose
face à la multiplication des antennes
relais un décret basé sur une étude
recommande d'appliquer un principe de
précaution
l'installation des antennes à moins de
100 mètres des hôpitaux ou des écoles
est même interdit mais l'inquiétude des
riverains perd six j'ai deux enfants et
petit secteur pour la santé de mes
enfants
certains se plaignent même d'électro
sensibilité en 2006 cette femme en
décrivait les symptômes
j'entendais si clément des sons des sons
qui sont très très forts et au moment où
ces sons sont très très forts que joe
réceptionne j'ai des vibrations derrière
l'oreille droite assez que dans la
mâchoire mais le lien entre ces
symptômes et les antennes relais n'a
jamais été établie persuadés du
contraire certains passent à l'action
les sabotages d'antenne se multiplient
exemple ici à marseille en 2009 la toute
nouvelle antenne relais orange aurait
semble-t-il été incendiés délibérément
selon le procureur de la république
l'hypothèse de court-circuit
accidentelle est à exclure
aujourd'hui le déploiement de la 5g a
remis le feu aux poudres
ces derniers mois les actes de
vandalisme contre les antennes-relais se
multiplient dans toute l'europe
[Musique]